retrouvez manger ses voté
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]
c'est absolument splendide mais
décidément ce soleil flamand est trop
vif pour mes yeux oui bonjour nous
sommes ce matin dans le département du
Nord sur le mont Cassel un des trois
mondes cette Flandre française et j'ai
rendez-vous avec Valérie Létard c'est la
sénatrice du Nord elle est également
vice-présidente du Sénat et elle
m'attend dans son hôtel de Hainaut mais
c'est à Valenciennes c'est assez loin
allez on prend la route
[Musique]
où est-ce que vous me recevez là dans ce
beau bâtiment alors je vous reçois dans
le siège de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de Valenciennes
Métropole c'est l'historique centre
hospitalier de ce territoire qui a
failli disparaître parce que lors de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ce bâtiment a
brûlé pendant 14 jours pendant 14 jours
sans discontinuer ici on parle beaucoup
évidemment de ce patrimoine
immobilier et historique mais le vrai
patrimoine des Hauts de France et du
département du Nord c'est les gens les
gens du Nord ces fameux gens du Nord à
ceux qui vous connaissent m'ont dit mais
elle est venue à la politique et au
Sénat par les gens justement par ces
gens du Nord vous savez Vincent j'ai
commencé
et on va dire ma vie d'adulte par
m'engager vers le social j'ai fait une
école d'assistante sociale pourquoi
parce que j'ai vécu un moment où toutes
les usines fermées où on a vécu une
misère sociale et culturelle qui m'a
profondément touché j'ai eu envie de
m'intéresser aux autres et puis je me
suis engagé dans une nouvelle politique
publique qui se mette en place qui
s'appelle la politique de la ville et
puis j'ai rencontré Jean-Louis Borloo en
98 Jean-Louis m'a proposé et bien de
l'accompagner dans une liste qu'il
portait aux élections régionales et tout
simplement de passer de l'engagement
professionnel à l'engagement politique
pour porter cette ce vécu de terrain et
puis en 2001 élection sénatoriale arrive
première élection
avec un mode de scrutin différent celui
qui amenait un scrutin proportionnel
paritaire c'est-à-dire un homme une
femme dans les listes sénatoriales nous
étions 7 femmes dont le groupe centriste
du Sénat quand je suis arrivé en 2001
sur 55 sénateurs et ça a progressé deux
mandats en mandat tout ce que j'ai pu
ressentir comme quelques fois un justice
ou comme besoin sur lequel il fallait
aller se battre pour moi c'est ça
l'action publique l'engagement politique
c'est et dès les plus fragiles mais
aussi des territoires qui en ont besoin
ce territoire il a beaucoup souffert il
a beaucoup aidé l'économie de ce pays et
il avait besoin d'être défendu au delà
des étiquettes politiques aussi alors si
on regarde votre parcours qui vous a
mené d'ailleurs à être deux fois
secrétaire d'État donc ministre je
dirais autant au service des gens que de
l'écologie donc les territoires et les
gens c'est qu'on retrouve au travers de
toute votre engagement alors
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin on va
considérer qu'aujourd'hui c'est moi et
les téléspectateurs pour visiter votre
département j'ai besoin de vous je vous
emmène
[Musique]
nous voilà partis sur les routes de
l'Avesnois en direction de la bleue du
Nord une race de vache sauvée par Jules
qui nous reçoit dans son exploitation
puis nous irons découvrir ce qu'est un
estaminet entre café et auberge très
très flamand ambiance Flandre française
nous goûterons ensemble le fromage le
boulet de Cassel une petite mimolette
qui a beaucoup à dire avant d'aller
s'occuper de légumes de saison vous le
verrez au chantier d'insertion la ferme
et nous irons voir ensemble une bonne
bière de garde une bière du Nord avant
d'aller cuisiner chez le chef Nicolas
Gauthier Armentières allez en route
[Musique]
où est-ce qu'on va là
de vaches bleues du Nord
ici
c'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle le
bocage avait noir on le voit autour de
nous des prairies qui demandent à être
paturées par des vaches qui sont
adaptées à ce climat ce sont des races
qu'on doit préserver grâce à Gilles et
bien on y arrive qui nous attend là-bas
bonjour Gilles bonjour
comment allez-vous
votre lait il sert à quoi il sert à
faire du Maroilles alors on était dans
une coopérative où on pouvait
entre guillemets faire du départ ferme
en direct et donc j'avais une fromagerie
qui venait chercher mon lait bio pour
faire du Maroilles bio
ça a changé bah oui défini quelques
jours maintenant on est parti sur une
coopérative juste à côté ici
ukanel on les parle là-bas pour faire du
principalement du lauht quoi et pourquoi
changer alors
nous c'était tout simplement pour des
raisons économiques quoi du marché ouais
ouais on avait pu c'est on est sur une
période où c'est vraiment très très
bizarre quoi je suis là cette année on a
même vu du lait bio à 420 euros les 1000
litres d'accord la tonne
les conventionnel qui a monté jusque 600
euros quoi
dans le même temps dans le même temps
dire que le bio était à 20% 25% moins
cher là je vous parle de l'extrême de
l'écart maximum là à l'heure actuelle on
est revenu sur du lait conventionnel à
480 à peu près et du lait bio à 520 donc
là on est dans une logique normale
il y a une forte demande sur le
conventionnel qui fait que le lait
conventionnel vaut plus cher que les bio
a certains moments et puis
malheureusement de toute façon on le
voit il y a des éleveurs qu'on bio qui
sont repartis en conventionnel quoi le
marché des réguliers complètement ou
alors au départ c'était 70 euros les
1000 litres de plus que le prix du
conventionnel et en 2016 j'ai pas peur
de le dire on n'est pas ça en bio parce
qu'on a été chercher la plus-value qui
avait aussi derrière oui parce qu'on a
trop le temps de s'alouiller quand on
vit dans les villes mais un paysan un
agriculteur c'est un chef d'entreprise
quelqu'un qui doit faire vivre son
entreprise sa famille et tout en
respectant son territoire ce qui est pas
toujours simple merci Gilles de nous
avoir reçu
on vous souhaite que le prix du lait bio
remonte un peu
ça ça ferait du bien bon bah alors
écoutez c'est sincère et bravo pour ce
que vous faites merci bien avec la même
passion merci pour tout
[Musique]
alors là on quitte la baignoire
direction la Flandre direction oxel art
où nous allons nous avons rendez-vous à
l'estaminet du village
oh mais c'est magnifique entièrement
rénové complètement bonjour bonjour Chef
bonjour comment allez-vous ça va bien
ça c'est très traditionnel Monsieur le
Maire en Flandre l'estaminet c'est un
peu le lieu social quoi où les gens se
retrouvent dans le village ouais c'est
vraiment un lien social quoi et puis
dans notre commune qu'on a été 25 ans
sans activité au sein de notre centre
bourg et on voulait recréer quelque
chose qui donne l'image aussi du Nord et
de la Flandre on s'est dit pourquoi pas
un bel endroit où les gens puissent se
rencontrer autour d'un bon verre d'une
bonne assiette mais alors quelle est
l'implication
de la municipalité dans un endroit comme
celui-là donc elle a fait l'acquisition
on a fait les travaux puis après il
fallait trouver quelqu'un qui le gérait
ça c'était la grande question parce que
nous on est incapable de faire ça un bel
endroit comme ça pour une commune de
combien d'habitants Stéphane aujourd'hui
on a 5 18 habitants 518 habitants en
fait ils sont tous là
et puis personne mange à la maison alors
c'est vrai que les habitants du village
viennent régulièrement et joue bien le
jeu et nous ça nous satisfait énormément
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une carte avec
tous les producteurs locaux chez qui
vous fournissez c'est important de tout
le monde en avance et puis voilà on
traitement avec les gens du secteur
j'entends des cris d'enfants il y a des
enfants ici
on reçoit aussi la cantine scolaire
la cantine de l'école c'est dans
l'estaminet
pourquoi vous m'avez amené ici hein vous
le saviez vous le saviez depuis le début
qu'on allait voir des Minos
je ne pouvais pas ne pas vous amener ici
en venant dans le Nord on doit venir
voir cet exemple incroyable mais ce qui
mange la même chose tu manges quoi tout
à fait la même chose parce que bon au
départ c'était un petit peu compliqué
voilà quand on leur met des légumes
anciens des choses comme ça ils
connaissent pas forcément et vous les
voyez changer dans leurs habitudes
d'alimentation ou petit à petit en début
d'année quand on les reprend en fin
d'année
ils sont ouverts
mais j'ai assez envie d'interroger les
enfants pour savoir s'ils sont si
contents que vous le dites bon chef je
vous laisse retourner en cuisine il y a
du boulot et nous on va monter à l'étage
voir les enfants merci
[Musique]
bonjour les enfants bonjour Mélanie
bon pour qui est-ce qu'on mange mieux
ici qu'à la maison
oui d'accord on comprend que tous les
habitants d'Auxerre viennent ici dans
cet état minet alors qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça coûte à la commune et
qu'est-ce que ça coûte aux familles le
repas ici en fait nous la commune elle
paye le repas à 7,15 et nous on demande
aux parents 3 euros c'est une très bonne
opération parce qu'on avait une grande
salle des fêtes donc il fallait chauffer
le matin il fallait allumer la cuisine
il fallait tout faire et donc on a pu
toutes ces charges là et on doit plus
acheter le repas sous vide non plus et
c'est même une économie et puis en plus
sans parler de la qualité du repas bien
sûr Valérie c'est un exemple pour tout
le département ça en France ce qui se
passe ici au solaire c'est vrai que
c'est un exemple pour beaucoup d'autres
communes beaucoup essaient de faire et
si on est là et si on en parle je pense
que c'est pour que ça fasse aussi des
petits des émules et dire à tous les
maires de petites communes que on peut
trouver des solutions de cette qualité
tout en faisant des économies alors j'ai
vu au menu et dans les assiettes le
boulet de Cassel c'est le fromage local
ça oui oui 100% et il vient d'où alors
il vient de la ferme des Templiers
à 100 m sur la place vous croyez que je
peux aller lui rendre visite avec
Valérie pour goûter le boulet de cassis
bon ben merci les enfants au revoir
salut
[Musique]
bonjour ah la jeune casse bonjour
bonjour on venait voir Marie-Christine
je sais pas si elle est là
c'est par où la porte
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Marie-Christine bonjour
Vincent
en train de tourner ses fromages cette
cave c'est une cave traditionnelle quand
vous êtes entrées ici j'ai vu votre
regard s'allumer Valérie parce que mon
grand-père était agriculteur éleveur et
il avait une ferme qui ressemble
beaucoup à celle-ci quand on est ouvert
la porte de la cave j'ai eu l'impression
d'entrer dans la cave de mon grand-père
qui était exactement de même chose le
voilà ce fameux boulet de Cassel alors
qu'est-ce que c'est comme fromage de
poulet le boulet de Cassel à la base
c'est une mimolette d'accord donc quand
on a commencé la fabrication du fromage
nous avons fait des gros fromages
de 2 et 4 kg et petit à petit on s'est
dit ben on va personnaliser notre
production en faisant des des petits des
mini voilà des mini et puis faut
rappeler quand même que autant le gouda
et les dames sont des fromages
néerlandais autant la mimolette c'est
français bien sûr elle a ses origines
dans les Flandres c'est pour ça que nous
on a voulu recréer ce fromage ça c'est
un fromage qui est fermier le bolet de
Cassel c'est vous qui produisez tout
votre lait bien sûr et puis mes vaches
sont nourris à base d'aliments qui sont
produits dans mes champs et qu'est-ce
que vous avez comme race de vaches pour
faire cette ce beau fromage la rouge
flamande la rouge flamande
bien de chez nous alors on va laisser le
fromage rouge et on va aller voir les
vaches rouges
[Musique]
combien d'éleveurs de rouge flamandes
dans la région je dirais une petite
dizaine mais c'est vrai que la rouge
flamande elle a un lait qui est très
riche mais elle produit moins que la
primo Stein par exemple c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a abandonné au bénéfice de la
primolstein pour une question de
rendement mais pas de goût exactement si
vous avez privilégié la qualité le goût
la particularité est-ce qu'on peut aller
le goûter enfin ce boulet de Cassel
évidemment avec plaisir vous avez
forcément un petit magasin de vente un
endroit où vous accueillez le public
[Musique]
ici vous êtes dans la petite boutique de
la ferme et je vous présente Lucile et
Charlotte donc ici on travaille entre
filles Charlotte s'occupe des animaux et
Lucie c'est la fabrication
mais ma fille
tient un magasin de produits régionaux à
Cassel tout le monde est dans
l'alimentaire voilà le boulet de Cassel
on le retrouve dans son collège Marie
tradition en or à Cassel en tout cas
c'est une affaire de femme tout à fait
oui je peux vous faire goûter le fromage
maintenant
prenez la prenez ce qu'il y a dans la
cave même
la production d'un si bon fromage mais
vraiment j'irais bien visiter faire un
petit tour à la boutique de produits
régionaux de votre fille oui pourquoi
pas oui pourquoi pas sauf que moi j'ai
rendez-vous dans un chantier insertion
chez un maraîcher vous savez quoi je
vous laisse avec Marie-christine merci
beaucoup et puis on se retrouve tout à
l'heure mais promis une bonne bière
bonne bière
je vous laisse à tout à l'heure on se
retrouve pour la bière
[Musique]
Bienvenue à la ferme les amis mais
vraiment à la ferme c'est le nom du site
le chantier d'insertion la ferme je vais
voir la responsable c'est Anne Céline
doit être à l'accueil ah bah je la vois
là Anne Céline bonjour merci de
m'accueillir
en ce moment ah bah il fait un peu un
peu frais dehors alors expliquez-moi en
un mot c'est quoi la structure ici parce
que il y a plusieurs lieux oui tout à
fait ici vous êtes du coup à
l'association visa et sur le site de
Wavrin on a trois structures donc on a
une pension de famille il y a aussi un
centre d'hébergement de réinsertion
sociale qui se trouve juste ici et le
troisième service du coup c'est
l'atelier chanté d'insertion où je vais
vous amener pour voir un petit peu ce
qu'on fait et là on accueille des
salariés en insertion on a 10 tunnels de
600 mètres carrés donc en permanence il
y a 25 salariés qui sont du coup
encadrés avec Hervé Rudy Hervé Rudy
j'imagine bonjour Rudy mais attendez là
je crois que j'ai une hallucination on
est bien en automne
au mois de novembre et ce sont des
fraisiers avec des fraises
dans le Nord
quelle température il fait d'habitude
ici à cette époque ici on doit être
autour de 0 degré et là on est plutôt
entre 10 et 15 quoi
je peux
mais sucré en plus pour Vincent je vais
vous laisser entre de bonnes mains je
vous laisse avec Hervé Rudy
merci merci mais alors en ce moment si
je comprends bien on est complètement
décalé qu'est-ce que vous produisez en
ce moment ici vu le les températures
qu'on a une normalement on devrait plus
avoir d'aubergines de poivrons de piment
et on en a encore on produit encore un
petit peu aubergines poivrons les
cultures d'été on m'a dit on va tourner
dans le Nord je dis je vais aller voir
les chicons les endives on peut on peut
voir quand même
voilà on devrait être en production
d'ordive depuis 15 jours on devrait
commencer les récolter la fois c'est
prête pour l'implantation vient
d'enlever les tomates on en reparle
normalement on est en production
d'endives et vu les températures qu'il
fait si on les aurait plantées elles
auraient monté tout de suite en fleurs
et c'est pas possible quoi
non parce qu'on est d'accord que là on
parle d'une salade qui est quand même
l'icône de ce département du Nord enfin
je veux dire
si on n'a pas d'endives ici il y en a
nulle part
vous vous êtes faites partie du
personnel encadrant vous êtes issu d'une
famille qui est de d'agriculteurs de
maraîchers du tout du tout à la base
j'étais boulanger j'ai travaillé en
biscuiterie j'ai fait des gaufres
pendant 5 ans ça au bout d'un moment on
travaille à la chaîne au sein des
plaisirs et j'ai coupé mon contrat et au
bout de un an et demi de chômage j'ai
découvert la ferme des petites et il la
ferme et bah je me suis découvert une
passion et j'ai eu la chance aussi de
signer un CDI et je suis passé en cas de
technique avec mon collègue c'est nous
qui gérons tout le site Hervé quand il y
a la différence avec une exploitation
qui ne serait pas un chantier
d'insertion le temps que vous passez
avec chacun
classique
il y a très peu de main d'oeuvre
aujourd'hui même en maraîchers ici on a
25 personnes qu'on essaie de remettre
dans le travail dans des habitudes des
horaires du travail et puis et puis
lorsqu'on découvrir le goût des légumes
aussi important aussi parce que des gens
qui sont très élus les gens se sont
éloignés d'aussi de la terre des
produits de la terre et on leur donne
des compétences même si c'est pas du
maraîchage des compétences transférables
en fait pour d'autres métiers vous
m'avez parlé de piment tout à l'heure
ils sont pas trop loin ils sont juste à
côté
parce que je vous crois pas en fait
voilà les piments
et c'est insolite d'avoir du piment
cette saison parce que évidemment les
serres sont pas chauffés donc c'est dans
leur climat naturel bienvenue à Wavre au
Mexique
bon merci Hervé merci beaucoup merci
Rudy merci à vous j'ai du chemin parce
que là sénatrice maintenant il faut que
je retourne la voir il y a pas de souci
comment on dit on dit hasta lue
maintenant que Wavrin est au Mexique il
faut s'adapter
alors là Valérie on sait où on est quoi
la brasserie familiale Duick nous allons
voir Mathieu Mathieu duc dernières
génération de brasseurs indépendants de
cette famille qui compte dans le
territoire la bière de Jean Lain il
incarne parfaitement
[Musique]
donc c'est immense ici ça a dû bien
grandir en s'entend bonjour
madame la sénatrice bonjour
Vincent écoutez je me demandais dans
quel lieu on se trouvait ici c'est quoi
ces grandes pubs là dans la salle de
fermentation on a juste au-dessus de
notre tête de la bière on commence à
faire de la bière Valérie la bière
faisait partie des des produits fermiers
du département et avait place sur la
table comme les comme les produits
alimentaires ça fait partie de
l'identité et de la vie quotidienne des
habitants du Nord les enfants même et
bien on est en vente bière un verre de
bière à table moi quand j'étais gamine à
l'école même on trouvait de la bière à
la cantine de l'école on vous servait de
la bière alors c'était dans les années
60-70 aujourd'hui on peut dire que ça
s'est étiré dans les deux sens des
grands groupes qui possèdent la majorité
des bières dans le monde des
microbrasseries qui ont fait leur
révolution il y a une vingtaine d'années
et vous vous êtes un peu dans la middle
classe vous êtes entre les deux
exactement il y a pas de jugement sur
les marchés qu'on vendus mais c'est un
peu le fil de l'histoire et nous on
s'est toujours battu voilà pour pour
éviter ça mon grand-père mon papa moi
aujourd'hui voilà des hommes de rachat
on en reçoit et on reste une brasserie
familiale indépendance on y tient on
tient le patrimoine là je pense qu'on
représente quelque chose et
effectivement il y a un renouveau avec
les microbrasseries depuis une quinzaine
une vingtaine d'années et ça c'est top
on pourrait le voir sur des brasseries
comme les nôtres comme une menaces en
fait ça a dynamisé le marché vous vous
êtes quoi la quatrième cinquième
génération c'est un peu particulier
parce que c'est la quatrième génération
ici à jour là mais mon arrière est un
grand-père était déjà brasseur à Zegers
Captain voilà dans les flancs de
françaises également il y a eu aussi
beaucoup de bière je trouve que vous
racontez formidablement l'histoire mais
j'espère que je vais la retrouver dans
le verre de bière il faut qu'on goûte
quand même évidemment vous y emmène on
va dans votre bureau on va dans mon
bureau là où il y a toute l'histoire qui
a commencé
exactement
on vous suit
[Musique]
la sénatrice merci beaucoup merci
Mathieu dites-moi après la salle de
fermentation on voit que c'est quand
même beaucoup plus traduit votre bureau
c'est pas des c'est pas des locaux qui
date dit à cela la maison date de 1840
mais c'est surtout la maison familiale
là où c'est installée mais
grands-parents en 1922 juste derrière
moi mon grand-père est né dans cette
pièce quand vous rentrez dans votre
bureau vous y pensez parfois le premier
jour où j'ai commencé la mainerie j'ai
une chair de poule là d'ailleurs
l'émotion est tombé dessus
à la famille
[Musique]
Valérie on est Armentières donc
périphérie de Lille et je vous emmène au
restaurant nature rencontrer le chef
Nicolas Gauthier chef étoilé
d'Armentières il va nous faire faire la
cuisine qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme
recette qu'est-ce que tu nous as prévu
une recette de la région traditionnelle
qui est où elle chante en fait contre
facilement dans les estaminer alors le
Wels à la base c'est quand même une
tranche de pain trempée dans la bière
traditionnellement un peu lourd un peu
gras enfin voilà ça tient encore et tout
nous en fait on l'a revisité et on l'a
on l'a retravaillé de façon beaucoup
plus légère beaucoup plus aérienne qui
peut se permettre du coup de le faire
remise en bouche en entrée légère avant
qu'est-ce que tu as pris comme fromage
donc là on est sur du monde écart c'est
l'autre monde
parce que nous on a vu les boulettes
Cassel du mont Cassel juste en face quoi
en fait on a là on a utilisé le boeuf
alors nous on est sur de la rouge
flamande c'est extraordinaire alors là
qu'est-ce qu'on est localement
on va mettre d'abord notre crème liquide
autant de crème que de fromage et là on
a la moutarde on a 50 g de moutarde
là ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on va y mettre
à fondre tout doucement là on va y
incorporer en fait la bière bon te
laisse cuisiner Nico pendant ce temps-là
je voudrais un peu revenir sur quelques
moments de notre journée Valérie d'abord
c'est un département qui est très
composé sur le plan des territoires et
des paysages mais le département du Nord
aux yeux des Français c'est une terre
industrie c'est la terre des mines mais
c'est aussi un terroir c'est aussi la
ruralité c'est aussi l'agriculture en
fait c'est un territoire très divers qui
est aussi une façade littorale comment
est-ce que ce département va relever le
défi de l'avenir et bien aujourd'hui ce
territoire se retrousse les manches se
reconvertit avec une population qui a
cette culture de l'industrie dont on a
besoin dans notre pays un pays moderne
c'est un pays qui a une industrie forte
qui a une souveraineté industrielle
ensuite il faut savoir que ce
département il est au carrefour de
l'Europe du Nord c'est à dire qu'on est
idéalement situé pour veut dire en
faisant en sorte de ne pas perdre ce
qu'est notre identité il faut qu'on soit
au rendez-vous de cette conjonction je
suis en train de sentir le fromage qui a
déjà bien fondu du côté de Nicolas voilà
amigo ça y est alors ça c'est notre
c'est notre base et nous on va utiliser
en fait le siphon va mettre cette
préparation là dans le siphon avec une
ou deux petites cartouches de gaz donc
là je l'ai préparé alors on dirait une
crème glacée c'est ça on a quelque chose
de très mousseux très léger très aérien
et là comme ça on retrouve en fait tous
les ingrédients de notre huile
traditionnel je peux avoir pour rentrer
à moi
merci beaucoup Nicolas merci Valérie
c'est tout ce qu'on aime d'en manger
c'est voter et nous on se retrouve
bientôt où est-ce qu'on se retrouve
Valérie mais sur public c'est là bien
sûr
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'était manger c'est voté avec Mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires
[Musique]